for many cloud users billing is just
something you deal with at the end of
the month but for larger teams and
organizations you'll hit a scale at
which becomes critical to understand
costs and to manage what you're paying
for on this episode of beyond your bill
will go into more depth on billing
accounts the payments profile and
managing billing permissions
[Music]
in the last video we looked at an
overview of how GCB resources are
organized in order to make sure those
resources are paid for correctly the
billing account and payments profile
need to be set up with the right
permissions see some GCP services have
free tears but you won't be able to go
beyond that tier without having a way to
pay for all the usage all services need
to exist as part of a project and each
project will need to have a single
billing account associated with it
though a billing account can have
multiple associated projects and the
billing reports an invoice will be able
to breakdown cost by project billing
accounts will also be directly linked to
a Google payments profile which sits
outside the cloud and is used to pay for
all Google services like G Suite and
Google Ads
if Google cloud platform is the only
Google service you use you may not
interact much with a payments profile
however it's important to keep track of
both billing accounts and payments
profiles especially for larger
organizations using multiple products
and services for GCP think of the
billing account as the way to organize
all your cloud specific billing and the
payments profile for how to actually pay
and view invoices both have their own
sets of permissions so you can control
who can view and manage this different
accounts we recommend setting up
multiple administrators for each of them
to safeguard against any issues and to
review them regularly it can even end up
being the same admins for both it's also
a good idea to only have a single
billing account in a single payments
profile to help make it easier to manage
them having multiple can make cost
management complicated down the road so
stick to as few as possible let's look
at setting up and managing an online
billing account which is paid with a
credit card or a bank account as your
company grows you'll want to work with
the GCP sales team to set up an offline
billing account which is paid with
invoices either way you need to be able
to manage your billing account
permissions to the GCP console and the
payments profile online in the console
you can open up the left navigation and
choose billing to see your current
billing accounts you may need to click
on manage billing accounts to get to the
right page and then click on create
account choose a descriptive name for
the billing account and choose a
location which determines the currency
each billing account and related invoice
can only represent a single currency
you'll then need to set up the payments
profile and can choose between
individual and business this can't be
changed later
you'll also be able to choose the
primary contact who will be the
administrator for the payments profile
again we recommend setting up multiple
admins or using a group to ensure a
reasonable level of redundancy the
payments profile will need a form of
payment such as a credit card or bank
account for more redundancy you should
actually come back later and add an
additional form of payment as a backup
as well as reviewing your administrators
and your notification settings once the
new billing account is created or if
you're working with an existing billing
account you'll be able to manage it from
the right side or the info panel the
best thing to start with is to add an
additional administrator you can do this
by clicking the add members button you
can add individual users this way or you
can add a group so there won't be any
access concerns when you need to find
the billing account admin in addition
you can also add billing account viewers
who have view only access to information
like how much each project associated
with this billing account costs as well
as billing account users who can not
only view the details but also associate
projects with this billing account once
you've setup your users you can then
create new projects or take existing
projects and associate them with this
billing account similar to billing
accounts you can manage permissions for
projects and folders by adding users and
assigning roles you can even create your
own custom roles and choose the exact
breakdown of permissions that a user can
have giving a user view access to a
project will let them see costs only for
that project as opposed to a billing
account viewer who can see costs for all
projects associated with that billing
account if you need to change
information about the payments profile
you'll do that from payments google.com
rather than the GCP console as I've
mentioned it's critical to make sure to
review the users and permissions on both
billing accounts and payments profile
regularly perhaps every quarter and to
make sure that your team knows who the
administrators are in case of any issues
you'll want to contact the billing
account administrators and have them
reach out to billing support as needed
with that setup you can now make sure
any GCP services are paid for correctly
and that your organization is set up to
manage costs check out the links for a
deeper dive and more best practices
around managing your billing account and
payments profile in the next video we'll
look at how to directly examine your
costs using billing reports in the GCP
console
[Music]